we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we got a
voicemail from the Eggman we haven't
heard from the Eggman for a little bit
he commented on yesterday on the bonus
show we covered the story of the sexual
impropriety allegations against beloved
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson
Eggman says he was surprised I covered
it take a listen to this hey Dave so
listen to yourself and I'm starting to
think a liberal Dave my buddy is not
going to mention the Neil grab-ass Tyson
controversy or the women have accused
him and then he did on the bonus show
and it just shows that you have equal
respect and disrespect for both vibes
and respect for women and disrespect for
men who don't and also respect for
evidence to see if it's actually true
sorry for calling him Neil grab-ass
Tyson but it just comes out so easily in
obvious you know doesn't sound like it
was really that bad either but I'm glad
you addressed it so hello brother yeah
Eggman I am upset actually that the
Eggman would even assume that I would
not cover allegations against prominent
leftists or or scientists or I don't
even know if Neil deGrasse Tyson
identifies as a leftist he seems pretty
pretty liberal to me but we have no
history on this show Pat of pretending
that allegations against the Left aren't
credible where his allegations against
the right are I mean like I said
yesterday on the bonus show these are
serious allegations against neil
degrasse tyson the fact that i think
he's a good science communicator doesn't
mean that I'm going to ignore any of the
allegations and like Carl Sagan's Widow
and Riaan said this is serious we
believe in evidence and we have to
follow the evidence I you know when it
comes to Anthony Weiner when it comes to
Al Sharpton whoever I will evaluate the
scope and seriousness of allegations but
we have no track record at all of
ignoring allegations like these against
the left well I have to correct the
record on a couple things here one you
said that the egg man hasn't called in
in a while that's not true we actually
took a question from him last week about
what we want our last meal to be if
we're ready executed and the other thing
is I pick about
90% of the stories for the bonus show
and that one was one of my choosing now
I'm not saying that you would have
ignored the story altogether we probably
would have covered it by now but I am
the reason why we talked about neil
degrasse tyson on yesterday's bonus show
that's right in my defense I had the
story on my list of possible stories for
the regular show didn't get to it
yesterday Pat had it on the bonus show
and I decided rather than delay it a day
we would talk about it yesterday on the
bonus show but it was Pat suggestion and
but listen Pat if I was trying to
obfuscate I would have just said let's
do a different story
of course then we've talked about Al
Franken and Anthony Weiner and other
prominent left-wing fingers figures who
have been taken down by the me to
allegations yeah so Eggman give me a
little bit of credit and apologies I
completely forgot that you're right Pat
we did take a question from the myth
last week it was such a wacky one that
it went completely out of my mind right
away we've got a great bonus show for
you today
membership patreon membership patreon
those are the two ways to get access to
the bonus show I'll speak to you then